Hi everybody. Um, and everybody
local and on live stream.
I want to welcome Tara
Richardson whitely here.
Her work as a plus size adventure
has been featured in New York Times,
self,
backpacker,
weightwatchers red book and also on
Oprah's life class. And Good Morning.
Good Morning America.
We're a very happy that she was able to
take time out of her schedule to come
visit us at Google and share her
story with us. Thank you. Oh,
thanks.
Yeah.
Hello.
Hi everybody. Um, I just want
to get the lay of the land here.
How many of you have climbed
Kilimanjaro? Anybody? Okay.
So nobody in the room has anybody here
once a climb? Kilimanjaro. Okay. One, two,
three, four, five, six. Does anybody want
to be convinced not to climb Kilimanjaro?
Okay. Three or four. Okay, got it. So, um,
I'll talk to you a little bit
about, um, you know, my story.
I speak all over the country
about my journey, um,
up mountains and sometimes
up the scale too. So I'll,
I'll share a little bit of both.
And since there are people in the
room who have the interest of climbing
Kilimanjaro, if you still at
the end of the presentation,
still have that interest, I'll go
over some tips and um, you know,
you can also contact me afterwards
also if you had any followup questions.
So my journey,
um,
up Kilimanjaro began when
I was more than 360 pounds,
and at that time I could
barely Hika staircase.
Um,
I couldn't even walk around the block
without being completely out of breath,
totally uninterested in continuing.
And I started to think to myself because
there was about to turn 30 years old
that I wasn't living life anymore.
And you know,
you might think to yourself,
maybe you'll meet somebody who's really
heavy or somebody who struggles with
weight and you just don't get it.
Like,
why did they get so big
so fast? Or, you know,
why can't they never get, get
it right? It's just food, right?
And it's not heroin or it's not,
um, you know, it's not alcohol.
But for me,
um,
my struggle with weight started when
I was nine years old and my parents
divorced and my father pretty
much up and left my life.
And then when I was 12, I was
sexually assaulted. So, you know,
it started with these
really big traumatic things.
That's when I started to
use food for comfort and um,
you know,
it started with these huge things.
But then little by little I used food
for everything and I really truly
sugarcoated my life where I wasn't
feeling happy, I wasn't feeling sad,
I was just feeling pretty comfortably
numb because even when, you know,
my parents were on the brink of divorce,
I literally would hide in the Pantry,
like to hear, to just drown out
their screamings by chewing food.
And when I was in the midst
of being sexually assaulted,
the only thing I could think of to make
it stop and to get out of this situation
was to get up and go to the kitchen
and offer the guy something to eat.
And it threw him through such a loop
that it kind of ended right there at that
moment.
So in many ways food saved me,
but as I was approaching my 30th birthday,
because at the time I thought that
was getting pretty old now 40.
Um, I started to think like, well,
I'm not getting any younger and I have
so many things that I want to do with my
life and I knew that I really,
I really wanted it to be a hiker girl
because even though I wasn't active at all
and I wasn't exercising and I wasn't
really a member of a gym or anything like
that,
my life would light up.
My mind would just come into that dream
phase anytime I would get one of those
adventure travel catalogs in the mail.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Those glossy pictures of the Alps
and Machu Picchu and Kilimanjaro.
But at that time I used to do what a
lot of people who struggle with their
weight. Do I say to myself, well, I'm
going to do that when I lose weight.
And like, like I would say to myself,
I'll go to the doctors when I lose weight,
I'll buy that dress or I'll buy something
fancy to where when I lose weight.
So as I approached this birthday,
I realized that, you know,
it was time to just get
moving no matter what.
And I decided that I
would just start to hike.
I would start to just be a hiker girl.
And even though I'm not,
um, a Patagonia model,
of course I could start with
things like a water bottle.
I could carry a water bottle,
I could take flat hikes as I live in
New Jersey and there's lots of those.
Um, and the more I hiked, the more
I enjoyed it. My husband, he's,
he's actually a marathon or
he's done seven so far. Um,
so he would hike with me and he would
just go up on the trail and he would be
far, far ahead of me and then he'd
tap his leg like it was calling a dog.
And instead of yelling at him,
I would muster my energy to
go faster and hike harder.
And suddenly I was the one who
is picking the harder trails.
I was the one who was,
um,
I was the one picking more
strenuous things to do.
And so as I got moving with this journey,
I started to think about
like I need a goal. Right?
And so I pick this particular
mountain as a goal.
Does anybody happen to know where it is?
No,
it's called camel's Hump and it's Vermont
second highest fake because it looks
like the back of the
camel. And so, um, anyway,
I chose this mountain in particular
because when I was in college at the
University of Vermont,
that's when my weight went
over the 300 pound mark.
And obviously I wasn't doing
any hiking at the time.
The only walking that I did was to the
bars because they had 25 cent draft night.
And that seems to make a lot of
financial sense to me and to class.
And so even though I grew up in Vermont
and I did hike camel's hump and during a
fourth grade field trip, cause that's
what they do on field trips in Vermont,
they hike mountains. Um, when I was
in college, my friends said, hey,
it's a beautiful day. A lot like it
is today. Great Sunshine. It's June,
let's go hike camel's hump. So I thought,
hey, okay, sure, I'll go along with you.
And 20 minutes into this five hour hike
I was just completely sucking wind.
I mean, absolutely out of
shape, unable to continue.
I had that feeling that many marathoners
do at like mile 20 where you know you
have lead leg and you
can't move another inch.
And so I told them everything like,
oh,
I haven't been feeling well
and I think my stomach hurts.
I must have eaten something funny.
But the truth of the matter
is I wasn't moving at all.
And instead of having it being
one of those Oprah Aha moments,
that moment where you know,
everything changes.
I went to the bottom of the mountain that
day and I ate the two things that were
in my backpack, a half pound
bag of m and m's and a leader,
a half liter bottle of diet coke. Because
I mentioned I'm not so good at math,
so I thought they equal each other out.
But for years and years, I live that way.
And I decided that if I was going to hike
and I was going to be a hiker girl and
I was going to move more,
I needed to conquer camel's hump.
And so I hiked and I hiked.
And on the eve of my 31st birthday,
I, you know, I conquered camel's hump.
And the funny story about that
is that I trained and I trained,
I trained on one of those
moving staircases, you know,
the staircase that never ends and you
have one of those at your gym. Um,
that was like my best friend
while training for this. And um,
I thought about it every day, how I'm
going to go to the top of camel's hump.
And I decided I was going to do a sunrise
hike because I thought that sounded
glorious and amazing and like one of
those once in a lifetime kind of hikes.
So I get up to the top of the
mountain and I'm hiking by myself,
and then I'm like, Geez, I don't
have anybody to take my picture.
And so suddenly this woman
and her daughter start
walking up with a dog and I'm
like, oh, this is such an
incredible hike. You know, how many,
how long have you been training
for this? And they're like, oh,
we do this every morning mountain.
So I was joining a different
kind of lifestyle, you know,
even though it was exciting
and new for me, um,
this is something that
other people did every day.
And so I was really kind of joining the
club when it came to hiking. I also,
you know, once I conquered
Campbell's hump, well then
the sky's the limit. Right.
Um,
then I went down to the bottom of the
Grand Canyon and thankfully back up again
because that is 10 miles of brutal up.
Has Anybody done the Grand
Canyon here? Yeah, it's rough.
I mean you really have
to time your arrest,
how much food you're eating and how much
water you can bring. It's a real, um,
endurance test. And then, um,
then we took on Vermont's highest,
um, peak, which is Mount Mansfield,
which to this day is the hardest
mountain that I ever hiked because,
well the truth is,
is that we ended up hiking down
the wrong side of the mountain.
So thank goodness the Vermont
brewer's fest was the same day.
So,
so as I was doing all this hiking,
all this amazing hiking, taking care
of my body, this great thing happened.
I started to lose a lot of weight,
so much weight that I had
lost almost a hundred pounds.
And this is very strange.
Things started happening
to me whenever I'd go,
especially to the bathroom at work. Women
would follow me in there and say like,
so what are you doing?
Why are you losing all this weight?
Did you get the surgery? Are you on weight
watchers? Are you doing South Beach?
Cause that was really hot at the
time. And so, um, and then I,
they'd be really interested in how long
did it take you and what did you eat and
what are you eating for
breakfast, you know, tomorrow,
and what are you gonna have for
dinner and can I join you for lunch?
And people would like turn and look
every time I got something to eat.
And it's all they cared about.
And these people who never once gave an
inkling about anything in my life wanted
to know everything that
was going in my mouth.
And for someone who had used food for so
long to kind of cover emotions and kind
of cover myself, it was
incredibly intimidating. Um,
so I decided that I wanted
to have another big goal,
but I also wanted to deflect
this attention I was getting.
So I started to set my
sights on Kilimanjaro.
Kilimanjaro is the highest mountain
that you can hike to the top of.
In other words,
no ice axe is no ropes,
no supplemental oxygen. Have
you seen into thin air, right?
It's not that it's a long drudgery kind
of journey where you're like five and a
half days up the mountain,
one and a half days down.
But you can do it on your own two
feet if you train really well.
So I figured that's going to be the
huge goal that I'm going to focus on.
And because it's such an iconic mountain,
I mean even in this room,
there's like five people who really
actually do want to do this. There's,
you can really do it to raise
money for almost any charity.
And so I thought since I'm going to
be doing it in Africa that I would do
something that would give
back to Africa. Um, and so I,
I did a little Google search
and I looked up, you know,
Kilimanjaro Climbs, AIDS, orphans.
Cause that's what I really wanted to
raise money for. And Lo and behold,
I found global alliance for Africa,
which is a Chicago based charity.
And the thing that they do to raise
money for their is Kilimanjaro hikes.
And so I signed up right away.
And then anytime that those women who
asked me about my weight asked me what I
was doing, I'm like, well,
I'm training for Kilimanjaro and here's
how you can donate to AIDS orphans that
I raised $12,000. So it's talk
about deflecting attention there.
Um, so to train for Kilimanjaro, you know,
there's a couple of things you should
know. One is that it is 19,000, 343 feet.
That's really high. It's in
Tanzania, Africa. The keys
to success are to go pull.
They pull a, does anybody know Swahili
in the room? Yes. Slowly. Slowly.
That's right.
That's the key to success.
And so if I was going to
sign up for a mountain,
then they said go as slow as you
possibly can. And I'm like, yeah, this,
this is Mike on a mountain.
Um,
the other keys are drink a lot
of water up to five liters a day,
and it's a lot. Um, and the other thing
is have a positive attitude. In fact,
the only way that you can tell if somebody
is not going to make it to the top,
if for those of you who actually
do want to hike the mountain,
if you're in your pre climb briefing and
somebody is complaining about how they
hate camping and they hate the outdoors,
they're pretty much like the Garner
by like day two to just so you know.
But otherwise you don't know who's
going to make it and who's not.
You Know Martha Stewart,
Martha Stewart made it
to the top and curry,
the newscaster for NBC,
didn't.
Martina Navratilova didn't.
So you just don't know by looking at
someone whether or not they're going to be
able to do it.
So I like those odds.
So to, to train, I focused on three
things. Strength, stamina, and spirit.
Strength is pretty obvious. You
know, you're doing a lot of hiking,
but you want to also strengthen your
quads and your back because you're holding
a backpack for so long and a strength.
Strengthen the muscles around your knees
so you support your body and all the
giants that need to get you there.
Stamina. Look, I live in New Jersey,
there were some mountains.
I actually had to hike twice,
two to get up to the level of
being able to climb Kilimanjaro.
But spirit I think was one of the most
important things where I took yoga
classes.
One because they do a lot of breath work
and I thought it was going to be really
important for me to feel like
I was in control of my breath.
My breath wasn't going
to be in control of me.
And so even though there were
breath exercises that I did,
it started to like really kind of get me
in the rhythm of really being conscious
of area in air out and
conserving error where I could.
But what I really loved about Yoga as
part of the training, yes, flexibility,
strength, all that stuff is great, but
every time I went down into Savasana,
you know the part where it looks like
everybody's sleeping and they did nothing
for like 45 minute class.
Um,
that was when I to imagine myself at the
top of the mountain before I got there
because they had to believe that I
could do this goal before I did it.
So you can do a lot of
roots up Kilimanjaro. I, um,
in my three climbs have climbed
the wrong guy route each time.
It's the root on the side of
the Kenya side of the mountain.
It's a little more remote.
Um,
maybe when we camped we saw two or
three other groups and that's it.
On the way down the mountain we went
the Coca Cola route, which is much more,
there's much more traffic. And so you
really did see a lot more people. Um,
a lot of people look at this middle
photo and they say, oh, how wonderful.
They're just starting
their, um, it's okay.
But a lot of people look at this
photo and they say like, oh, how cute.
They're just starting their
journey up Kilimanjaro.
And I have to explain to them like, no,
no, no, that's, that's four days in.
And you still have to do,
you have to like summit night is from
here up to the top and then halfway down
the mountain in one day it's 15
hours of hiking. So and, and,
and things like altitude headaches
are real. They're real concern.
And this is Lisa who actually did make
it to the top, but it was, you know,
50 50 whether or not she was actually
going to continue or not at that point.
So Hiking Kilimanjaro is an amazing thing.
You dream about it for months.
Do you prepare,
you visit rei more times than you
probably have in your entire life, right?
You spend more money on gear probably as
much as you paid for your plane tickets
but then comes some at night and when
you're at some at night and I mentioned
that you're a camping kind of high up
on that slope that I disappointed too.
When you start your summit attempt it,
it's 15 hours of hiking.
So why not start at midnight, right?
Cause you just get it started,
get it started and get it over with.
Um, when you open your tent door,
you were so high up that their stars
above you, there's stars beside you,
they're stars below you.
When you are so proud of yourself that
you've put on every possible layer of
gear, everything you look like,
that kid in a Christmas story,
and I can't put my arms down or you know,
um,
and you've managed to tie your shoe
laces it at about 15 or 16,000 feet.
That alone is like, you're so proud of
yourself that you can't even imagine.
Um, so then you walk out your
tent door and you join your group.
You try to stomach a
little bit of breakfast,
and then you start walking
in this formation with your,
with your guide,
and they're singing you Swahili loves
songs and lullabies as you're walking in
this beautiful formation lockstep.
Everybody's in this together.
And that's really wonderful.
For the first hour,
maybe the second,
but by the hour you're thinking,
I think this guide is lost because
unlike in the states where these,
these big trailblazers where you
know exactly where you're going,
there's,
you know,
I'm going to follow the red dot
trail all the way up the mountain.
There isn't that on Kilimanjaro,
there's just these gravelly trails of
screen near the top where you take one
step up and you slide halfway back and
you take another step up and you slide
halfway back.
And it is so incredibly frustrating.
So, um, then you're, you know,
you're really irritated at this point.
And by our four you're pretty much,
um, you've pretty much got your,
I quit speech down, like, listen,
I really want a fresh shower and a cold
beer or a cold water that comes from a
bottle, not from whatever water source
you've got this stuff from. Um, I,
you guys are like sisters or brothers
to me. You've lent me toilet paper.
I feel like we're family,
but I'm going to leave now.
I'm going down the
mountain the way I came.
So right when you feel like you just
cannot take this journey anymore.
That's when the sun comes up.
So on Kilimanjaro,
especially on summit night,
it is truly darkest before dawn.
That's when you really have to dig
in and just keep pushing forward.
When you feel like you just can't,
unless of course you're suffering from
something really like altitude sickness.
But if usually your mind gives
out before your body does,
um,
and if you're climbing Kilimanjaro usually
stop at Gilman's point where you can
have tea.
A lot of times the porters and guides
have tea for you there and you're so high
at this point that you watched the
sunrise over Africa and the horizon is
curved. And I, when I first noticed this,
I thought maybe I was tripping because
of the lack of oxygen, but another fee.
A lot of other people
confirm that it actually,
the horizon does look completely curved
because you are so high up on in the
world.
But maybe they had lack of oxygen to.
So from there you can go
onto [inaudible] peak,
which is the true summit of Kilimanjaro.
And the first time I did it, um,
I hiked with my husband
and for the record,
he's only done one of my three clients.
So with all my training, I kept thinking
about the way up, the way up, the way up.
But what goes up must
come down, right? And so,
um, it can be kind of fun. I mean
you, you're doing this scree running.
So now that scree that was so
devastating to you on some at nights,
so difficult to manage is kind of fun
because now you're doing this almost like
a vertical run down a beach.
Does that make sense?
So you're trying to,
Hank have fun with it where you're just
kind of running and running and running
and it really actually helps rinse out
the lactic acid that's kind of built out
in your,
in your body.
But you just try to enjoy the journey
down even though your legs kind of feel
like Jello for all the,
that you've put it through.
So as we're doing this,
as we're making our way down the mountain,
and that first time all we could think
about was getting to a hotel shelter,
anything over our heads, a warm meal
at a table on a plate, you know,
something that we could really
enjoy. And of course the shower, um,
our leader at the time, she said
to us, she's like, hey guys,
don't forget to look up
every once in awhile.
And so on this particular
trip and where are we?
We're at that moment on the mountain.
I looked up and their horizon and I
saw a mountain that looked a lot like
camel's hump. And I thought
to myself, you know, Gosh,
if I had never done Campbell swamp,
if I had never made that my giant goal,
I could never be here.
And so it really does make
a difference as small steps,
those intro interim goals.
So even if it's like a five k for you,
like something you've never done before,
you never know where that may lead.
And it might just lead to the five k and
that alone is a huge accomplishment and
camel's hump. At the time was a
huge accomplishment. But you know,
that interim goal led me
to the roof of Africa. So,
you know,
in the end I did lose a 120 pounds and um,
the women were very excited about that.
Who would follow me to the bathroom?
And after I came back from Kilimanjaro,
the next thing they wanted to know,
so what's your next adventure? What are
you doing? Are you going to do Everest?
I going to do much, you feed to a,
are you going to do, you know, if,
if wild were out at the time, they
would have been like, oh my God,
you totally got to do the
Pacific coast trail. Right. Um,
but I had a whole other adventure in mind.
It required another language and a lot
of new gear and that was to have a baby.
So, um, like a lot of women
who struggle with their weight,
I put on a ton of it back on
when I was pregnant. In fact,
I put on 70 pounds during my nine
months of pregnant pregnancy.
Um,
and I went from someone that had been to
the roof of Africa to someone who could
barely hike across my living
room cause I had Sciatica so bad,
which is like this lightening bolt
down your leg. And it was embarrassing.
It was embarrassing that I had done so
much in one year I lost all this weight
and then in months I put
half of it back on again. Um,
and so now those women wouldn't
even look me in the eye anymore.
They wouldn't hold the
door for me anymore.
Nobody really wanted to talk
about weight anymore with me.
And so I was really feeling stuck and
isolated and I started to do those things
that I did when I struggled
with my weight before,
like I bow out of events because
I felt like, oh, I'm too fat.
I don't want to go to that reunion.
I don't want to go that party. The,
I haven't seen this personal long time.
I wouldn't be in family photos. In fact,
there's almost no pictures
of me when I was pregnant.
And I think it's because I didn't
want people to take my picture.
I was embarrassed of how
I felt about myself. Um,
and I was really stuck and I
started to think about, you know,
what was it about that
first Kilimanjaro Climb?
How come I was able to really
rise above and just go do it?
And I thought to myself,
well,
it was because I was working for a cause
that was bigger than myself. You know,
whenever I didn't want to work out,
I thought about I'm climbing this
mountain for AIDS orphans in Africa.
I'm raising money for them.
Who am I to not eat well?
Who am I to not train today?
They're depending on me. Um,
and even though if I didn't make them
out the, the top of the mountain,
I still would have the donations,
still would have gone to the charity.
But I felt like I had a
responsibility to do my best.
And so in my post pregnancy
mind, I thought, well,
I've got a great plan.
I'm going to do something called the
save the world workout where I'm going to
do a different event for
charity every month of the year.
And that way I would force
myself to get out and you know,
be a part of an event where they
were raising money for charity,
where I have to sign up for it show up.
And it really did a great job of just
at least getting me moving again because
that's something I wasn't doing at all.
So even though some of the events
burns more calories than others, like,
um, you know, the, the
flying pig marathon,
I actually walked the
whole marathon course,
but the penguin plunge in Vermont,
which is jumping in lake
Champlain in Burlington,
Vermont in February,
where they actually have to cut out a
minivan size chunk of ice and you jump in
the water. That was more about,
you know, that was more about me,
like kind of getting out of my shell
again than it was about burning calories.
And I'm a little embarrassed about the,
um,
the profanity I used in
front of the former mayor of
Vermont, not Bernie Sanders,
but Peter, Peter Corvelle. Um,
but I think he might've
matched it a little bit,
but I'm not saying you did. So anyway. Um,
so it was this great year of just
kind of getting out, raising money,
doing fun things that I enjoy
it again and I thought, okay,
the best thing that I can do is to end
the year with the Kilimanjaro Climb and
that will finally get
me back in that space.
That same place where I was successful
with weight. I mean, because you know,
you see all the advertisements for weight
loss products, weight loss, surgery,
weight loss, this weight
loss pills, weight loss,
all of these programs that you can do.
People really want to
be in that place again.
And I desperately wanted to hang onto
something and I thought Kilimanjaro is
going to be the key to that.
And so I thought if I just ended
with the Kilimanjaro hike, um,
I was going to be able to do that.
So
I did all the events,
but the problem was I convinced myself
that I was just really good in altitude
and it's just a slow hike to the top.
It's all you have to do to get
to the top of this mountain.
Unfortunately it isn't. If you're
planning on climbing Kilimanjaro,
you want to give yourself four months
of training in that direction and that's
it.
You know,
you want to make sure you have time to
prepare your body and your mind for this.
But the most important thing that I did
not conquer was my challenge with food
because I didn't put 70 pounds back
on because I was just eating extra ice
cream.
I was doing the same things that got
me into trouble the first time I was
bingeing and my real red
flag with food is when
I can't admit what I ate.
In fact,
my real trouble point with food
is when I'm hiding what I've done.
So for those of you who don't struggle
with food, I'll just lay it out for you.
This is what it looks like.
I'm the mom in our family,
so I do the grocery shop right?
I come home with some ice cream for my
kids and for my daughter at the time and
my husband
and we have dessert and we have a nice
healthy portion of ice cream and that's
that. Everybody's happy. We go to bed
the next day while I'm working from home.
I think after lunch,
oh,
I could give some ice cream or sometimes
after breakfast I could use some ice
cream. I have a little bit,
I want to be done with it.
Then I returned to the fridge or
the freezer or a few minutes later,
maybe an hour later I want a little
bit more and then a little bit more.
And suddenly I'm like
eating the entire container,
like with a spoon in the freezer are
still open and suddenly I'm like,
oh my gosh,
this thing is almost gone now.
How am I a professional mom? Uh,
you know, a professional writer,
um, you know, a good mom, successful
and lots of other things. I mean,
I've raised money.
I'm a good person.
How is it that I can be
conquered by a cupcake?
And so then I do what I think
is the most logical thing.
I go back and I have to buy another thing
of ice cream to hide the fact that I
didn't eat the ice cream the first place.
Now,
this is when I'm really in trouble with
food and this is where I was on the eve
of this second Kilimanjaro Climb.
I hadn't dealt with how I was
feeling with food. In fact,
the hardest thing that I had to write
about and gorge was the scene right before
the second climb.
Um,
because I had purchased some candy in
the Amsterdam airport for my daughter and
my niece and nephew who are coming to
visit for Christmas and I eat it all,
every single bit of it on the
eve of a Kilimanjaro Climb.
So spoiler alert, I didn't make
it up the mountain that time.
In fact, it was, it was a pretty
devastating fail. And after that point,
if I was in the red flag territory before,
I was seriously,
seriously in trouble with food.
Um,
I did that kind of thing with the ice
cream like almost every single day.
So I didn't want to hike again.
I didn't want to hear
about Kilimanjaro again.
I didn't want anything to do with
mountains until a friend of mine said,
hey, remember that trip up Kilimanjaro
ever since you talked about it with me.
I've always wanted to go and I'd like
to do it to train for an iron man.
So my friend would also like to come with
me and together we will raise a dollar
per foot of the mountain for
the charity that you love.
So $19,343 was on the line for
Kilimanjaro if you come with us.
And then I had my husband's cousin
who is on the cover of gorge with me,
say to me, you know, I'm in a Rut.
I really need to get out of it.
Her mom died of cancer and then her father
was murdered on the roadside in Moab,
Utah, all within a couple
of years of each other.
And she was eating and she was shopping,
um,
to kind of get through those feelings.
And so she was putting on a
ton of weight and she's like,
I just need something to keep me going.
So all climb Kilimanjaro,
and I'll raise $5,000 for
global lands for Africa.
If you come with me and like talk about
like backwards peer pressure, right?
This is,
so now if I knew if I climbs that I could
raise an additional $5,000 for global
lines for Africa.
So now we're talking about $30,000 for
this organization that I really loved.
I mean,
that's more than enough money to actually
build a library in one of the slums in
Kenya or anything like that.
I mean,
there's so much that can be done
with bad amount of money, um,
for the programs that they use. So I
thought, okay, I'll do it. However,
if I do it, and this is the
story that's in gorge, um,
that I would need to do the work,
I would have to do the training again,
that kind of four to six months,
I've really, really training,
however I needed,
the most important thing that I needed
to do was to love myself where I was and
go from there. Because initially I
started to do that thinking like, okay,
well I'm going to lose 20 pounds this
month and 10 pounds every month until the
hike and that'll be
perfect. And I thought, no,
if I set myself up like that,
it's going to be a complete failure.
What I needed to do was to find a
trainer who would train me as I was,
that I could be able to climb the
mountain at the weight I was at.
I did things like,
I signed up for a half marathon in
Vermont called the mad marathon, um,
which is the most mountainous marathon,
half marathon I've ever walked.
It's incredible. And my husband
did that with me to help me train,
but more importantly I needed
to understand like what
is it about food that has
so captured me?
How come I eat?
How come I have this like pattern of
existing that is so dangerous to myself?
So if I was going to climb the mountain,
not only was I going to do it upon
my own strength and my own body,
I was also going to do the work to
understand the journey that I had been on.
And this of course was
no walk in the park.
I climbed the mountain as
if I was carrying, you know,
another person on my back.
I did the hiking as if I was doing that.
So I did things like I trained in,
in tell your ride with my
husband's cousin's Stacy. Um,
and you know,
PSA,
it's a lot easier to ski down a mountain
trail than to hike up it because that
was some serious hiking up,
some serious trails, those,
but it was so gorgeous when I got to the
top and I was doing actually altitude
training because you know,
those are like 12,000 feet,
14,000 feet peaks that we were hiking.
Um,
so when I was,
when I got to the mountain,
when I got to there the third time,
I was feeling pretty great about myself.
I was feeling like I was ready.
In fact,
so much so that,
um,
by the second day two people, two of the
four people who are with us for four,
including myself, were
feeling sick, feeling tired,
feeling like they had made a mistake.
Like they didn't really want it to come
up Kilimanjaro and how could I have said
yes to this crazy idea.
Um,
anyway, I started to feel
like, yeah, I feel good.
And even after that second
day on the wrong guy route,
which is 10 hours of hiking,
10 hours of just drudgery,
it's not a huge incline,
but it is a long slog.
The porters and guides actually
asked me if you know, hey,
do you need me to carry your backpack
like two or three times because they were
already carrying backpacks of my, you
know, fellow hikers. I'm like, no, no,
I feel good. And so, you know,
that night when I went to sleep I
was thinking, okay, it's so cold.
It was actually so cold that night that
our water bottles frozen our tents.
So you know, if you go camping a
lot, you know that kind of night,
like all you want to do is
put your sleeping cap on,
put yourself in your sleeping bag and
go to sleep so you can wake up for when
the sunrises and it could possibly be
a few degrees warmer when you wake up.
So as I was, um, as I was going to sleep,
I started hear rumblings in
Swahili and the tent next to me.
That's where the porters
and guides were hanging out.
And I don't know a lot of Swahili,
but I do know a couple things. The,
for most important thing that I know
is what they call me in Swahili.
My nickname on the mountain for
all three climbs was Mama Qube wa,
which means big woman, which
didn't bother me. You know,
that's the way they differentiate
me from the other people.
They know who they're talking about.
But then I started to hear laughter
and it wasn't like Mama Kubu.
I told this really funny joke and
I'm going to tell you what it is.
I knew at that moment that they were
making fun of me and so these are the
people that we were paying
to help us up the mountain.
And I started to feel for the first time
like, I'm not going to do this anymore.
I've done this. This is my third time
up the mountain. I know my way back.
I'll just get a ride to
the hotel and I'm out.
Because I started to think to myself
like, I, I'm not going to do this.
If the people that we're paying to
support us up the mountain don't think I'm
going to make it,
how could I possibly make it?
So I finally told myself to sleep.
I remembered things like when I was
doing spinning classes and they did,
you know these mantras and I totally
tried to get myself into the mode where I
was like, okay, I believe in me.
I'm going to ignore what they said.
But here's the thing about Kilimanjaro.
You can't push off things if it's raining.
You put on a rain jacket or you
will get soaked. If you're hungry,
you need to eat something or
you're going to be, you know,
you're not going to have enough
energy to do what you need to do.
If you're thirsty,
well then you're far beyond
being dehydrated and you
need to be drinking. Right?
So with the same thing goes with emotions.
It's a really great mountain to kind of
toil through something that you need to
figure out because the,
all you have time to do is think,
but you have to do something
with that emotion. And for me,
someone who's been struggling with their
weight for since she was nine years old,
I know when people are making fun of me
and I couldn't just put it off anymore
and I'll just do a quick reading
about what happened after that point.
So the next morning I
was still feeling it.
I was still feeling upset about
how they felt that, what they,
what they said about me.
However far I walked,
however much I tried to
think of other things,
the humiliation of last night
was there and it was raw.
I was overcompensating by being perky,
a cheerleader,
even if I would have never made it on a
team, let alone be on top of a pyramid.
But being perky and positive was how I
usually dealt with everything in public.
I needed to confront Kennedy,
but in such a way that he would continue
guiding me up the mountain safely.
So when it came time for a water in
pee break amid an outcropping of rocks,
I approached our guide.
What I always with what I always do,
when I'm upset or nervous,
I smiled.
I didn't want him to know that is
mocking words made me want to turn back.
So there I was swallowing my true
feelings, trying to be nice. After all,
his job was not an easy one.
He was already carrying
Tracy's backpack to help her.
But my cheeks burned.
I was always,
I always live with the feeling that I
couldn't or shouldn't speak up in the face
of bullies or my abuser or even my father.
I was swallowing.
I was used to swallowing my
words like 22 rifle shells.
So when it came time to
swap, say my words, I nearly
choked on the first syllable.
I want to talk to you
about something I said,
interrupting a Swahili conversation he
was having with our assistant guide last
night. I heard you. You were talking
about me. What were you saying? Sorry?
Kennedy said I was pretty
sure he was pretending.
He didn't know what I was talking about.
I heard you last night.
I heard you making the trails.
I do when I'm going up and down the trail.
I heard you making fun of
me. I was talking with some
porters who wanted to know,
are you sure she's going to make it?
I was answering them.
They don't believe you're
going to make it to the top.
Kennedy said he looked embarrassed,
maybe not because of what he said,
but for getting caught from
his tone the night before.
I couldn't help but think that he was
one of the people betting against my
success. I knew his laughter and
I believed he was laughing at me.
They don't believe it. I asked.
Yeah, Kennedy answered, looking away.
Did you make any money, Beth? Siast
you should. I said, bet on me.
Bet On me.
So that's the only the only time in my
life probably that I've been able to come
back with something that to say to
somebody who's made making fun of me and
middle schools just, I was,
uh, you know, an embarrassment.
Like I would just hear people making
fun of me and I would just run away and
then I'd think about it
like two days later on.
The only thing that I can think of of
why I was able to say something with such
power and convention conviction
and strength was because
Kilimanjaro allowed me
to be all strong. And so I can
ask for what I need for in life.
Um,
I can do things that I want to do because
I was finally standing up for myself.
Um, so my wish for you is that, you know,
whatever it is you want to accomplish,
if after this talk you want nothing to
do with Kilimanjaro, whatever it is,
whatever goal you have is
that you continue to bet
on yourself because it will
always pay off for you in the end.
So thanks.
And I'll take any questions that you have.
Um,
I'm planning a Kilimanjaro hike in June.
So first one normally
hike around the bay area.
So what do you think will be like most
surprising or shocking to me or what
should I do extra to
prepare? Okay, so, uh,
the most surprising or shock being
shocking is when you're shopping for hand
wipes, multiply the amount that you
think you need by about four or five.
Um, you know, the training
that you do is pretty obvious.
You want to hike up mountains,
you wanted to build strength,
you want to build endurance.
Um,
but the hardest part is the mental part,
you know,
going past what you think you
could possibly do on your own. Um,
that's hard.
But then also in,
during that when you feel kind of Yucky
about yourself because you have a shower,
I mean they give you,
at least the tour group that I went with
gave you water to wash up and stuff,
but you just feel so
grimy by the end of it.
And that can be kind of tough to
um, endure the physical, you know,
usually if, you know,
if you hike around home,
you do a great day hike and then you go
home or you go to a hotel and you shower,
that's, you know, backpacking is not
like that where you actually have to, um,
be where you are and continue being
in that mode for several days.
So really prepare for that.
The not only the physicality of the
mountain but the emotional part two.
Thanks. Yup. I want to know what
inspired you to write about this book,
the first book that you write.
I did write a book that I self published
called fat woman on the mountain and
that was about my first climb
and I self published that,
um, because I, it was 90% done
on my computer and I thought,
well I might as well just
share it with the world.
But this is my first book with a publisher
and I've been lucky enough to work
with seal press, which is actually
based, um, nearby in Berkeley, um,
their publisher for
women by women. But, um,
as I was working to get
the proposal ready, cause a
nonfiction book, you, you know,
you write a proposal, you don't have
to write the whole thing at first,
but you have to write a good portion and
know where the book is going. My agent,
Kim Burrell had mentioned that,
you know,
she was looking at the proposal and I was
really focusing on the mountain climb.
You know, I'm a fat person and I'm
climbing this mountain. Isn't that great?
You know, it was an adventure story
and she, and I had, uh, you know,
was, uh, what was a very difficult call
for her to make and say that, you know,
this is a great story. Of course it's
important for you to tell this story,
but I need you to be more,
um,
open with your struggles with food
because that is an equally as important as
this physical struggle to
hike a mountain. And, um,
she assured me, and then people, writers,
like Cheryl strayed, who's my teacher.
She wrote wild that it didn't matter
what I put on the table about my issues
with food because two thirds of the United
States struggles with weight and some
way,
shape or form.
And so it didn't matter
how open or embarrassing I
thought a story would be that
there would be a lot of people nodding
their head or understanding someone
else's behavior because of it.
And so that's what I decided to do.
And with that advice,
I actually change the title.
I had originally called
it big fat mountain,
which I still think it
was kind of good title,
but as I was writing the last
scene, um, which is in a gorge,
I thought,
oh my gosh,
it has to be gorge because it means so
many things stay too much in the low
point between mountains. Um,
and also slang for gorgeous.
But that's third of it though.
It's mostly those two meanings of course.
Um, so anyway, the paradigm of, you know,
sometimes you get some feedback and
even though it's difficult to take, um,
it really was important for me
to hear that. And really, um,
and right to that point.
And once when she did that,
I felt like the floodgates open.
I could share anything.
And in and thought woman on the mountain,
I shared about being sexually
assaulted in my father, you know,
not being a real big
part of my life, but, um,
in gorger really kind of let it all out,
which was,
it was really important for me to do.
Oh, you playing to play it again? Well,
I think it's safe to say it's time to
move on to other mountains. Um, you know,
Kilimanjaro three times. I mean, maybe
Oprah could asked me to climb it,
but that's about it. Um, but I,
I would love to hike Machu Picchu. Um, I,
I mentioned I studied with Cheryl strayed.
I did that in the French Alps.
So I did a lot of hiking when I was there.
But the most important thing for me at
this point in my life is that hiking
comes naturally to me.
So it's not something that I put a barrier
up because of my size. Um, or, you know,
have I lost 10 pounds? Have
I gained 10 pounds, you know,
wherever I'm at the scale that I love it.
In fact,
so much so that I'm an American hiking
society ambassador to share that the
outdoors are for everybody.
Um, but you know, they're,
my victories today aren't huge mountains.
They are things like, you know,
before I left on these two talks,
I did a talk at Purdue and um,
I made sure that, you know,
I had my seeds ordered for
my community garden plot,
so I had healthy things
for my family to eat. Um,
there are things like going to family
swim because putting a bathing suit on for
me it can be as intimidating as Everest.
Okay. Let's just be honest here, you know,
so that I actually am leading an active
life no matter where I am on the scale
for myself, for my kids, for my future.
So you mentioned wipes and they saw the
polls and I'd read the blogs, you know,
what,
is there any kind of equipment that you
needed that you didn't think you would
have needed or did you didn't read about?
Well the, you know, if you go
with a reputable tour company,
they will give you a supply list. So you
can feel pretty comfortable about that.
Um, the people that Rei won't
steer you wrong usually.
Um, I would say that the most important
thing for you to move money into his,
into your socks and boots. Okay. Um,
I am not a fancy bag kind of person,
even though there's a Bloomingdale's and
the next town over, I never go there.
But if I go to Rei,
I mean I dropped $300 on a pair of boots,
but it's worth it.
Um,
I bought a pair of a solos that actually
I took up Kilimanjaro three times and
all the training in between.
And the only reason I gave them away
at the end was because our guide was
wearing sketchers. Okay. You know,
and so you want to make sure, um,
as a side note,
if you do decide to climb the mountain,
you want to make sure that you're a
guide company really takes care of their
porters because it's, uh, you
know, it's considered a good job.
However, you know, you want to make
sure that they have good footwear,
that they have enough to stay warm because
you'll see how much you pack. And it,
um, it'll depend, you know, there's,
there's guidelines about
how many pounds it can be,
but then you see these porters
are carrying up all your
stuff and then there's a
tiny little backpacks. So, um,
think about that for sure. Um,
when you go,
but I'm hiking poles.
It's good to start training with them
even though you don't think you need them
because you know, it does take a lot of
your shoulders to kind of move with them.
Um, so you don't want to be
feeling like that is, um,
something new for you on the mountain.
You really don't want anything to
feel really totally new for you.
Any of your gear except for meeting maybe
gators because those go on the outside
of your pants.
So
one last follow up.
Sure.
I read somewhere that you wanted your
shoes to have a little bit of space so
when you come down your
towed isn't seemed cam,
but that seems kind of odd in the sense
that going up you don't really want
loose boots either. Huh? Was
that an issue when you came down?
Did you feel like your
toes are getting spam?
Well, yes and no. I mean it's a,
it's an interesting question. You want to
feel that with your outfitter. You know,
whoever's selling you your boots and
look up more online about that. I mean,
because I've had, you know,
my third climb, by the time
it got down the mountain,
I had this horrible blister,
which I won't describe because it's
probably like the adult content.
Like you don't want to
hear about that on my toe.
But I think it's because my laces
weren't tight enough. You know,
it was probably like too tired to
just go down to the tie them tightly.
So you know, you want to make sure
all those things are taken care of.
Another thing is you want to make sure
your toes are really well clipped and
your toenails. Because if you, if you
have two long toenails, that will also,
you'll lose a lot of toenails because of
that. So lots of chips, lots of footwear,
ask lots of questions.
I mean,
the people who work at outdoors stores
often do it because they love gear and
they love hiking. And so, um, if
they don't know than someone else,
I'm sure someone on their staff
has done a similar hike. Yeah.